(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Another world,
another time, another age.
Thra, a wondrous planet
circling three suns
and at its center, the Crystal of Truth,
the heart of Thra and
the source of all life.
Since the land was young,
Aughra protected the crystal,
for she knew that the crystal
connected all the creatures of Thra.
But closest to her
heart were the Gelfling.
Seven clans of Gelfling called Thra home.
From the proud Vapra in the
mountain city of Ha'rar,
the most cultured of the Gelfling
who rule over the seven clans.
To the fierce Stonewood who
dwell in the Endless Forest
renowned for their prowess in battle.
And the gentle Grottan, who
live deep beneath the ground
in perfect harmony with all of Thra,
forgotten by the world above.
For uncounted millennia, all
of Thra existed in perfect balance,
but then new beings came not of Thra,
the Skeksis. (ominous music)
They bewitched Aughra with
stories of the universe,
and built her an Orrery
so that she might discover
the mysteries of the cosmos for herself.
And so Aughra turned her eye to the stars.
(dramatic music)
and entrusted the Crystal
of Truth to the Skeksis.
(dramatic music)
(grunts)
Almost 1000 trine have passed since
the Skeksis declared
themselves lords of Thra.
(staff pounding the ground)
(sighs)
Now, once again, the Skeksis gather
in secret, as another day dawns,
to steal life from the crystal
they have sworn to protect.
(dramatic music)
(growling and sighing)
So they may replenish themselves,
cheat death by harnessing
the power of their treasure,
their prize, their prisoner, (sighs)
the Dark Crystal. (dramatic music)